ANDE PULLS UP AND
TREVOR ZEGRAS AND SCORE UP.
FLAT FOOTED COMING OVER THE
MAINTAINED BY
FOEGELE.
AGAINST TROY TERRY.
BACK DOOR AND ONE TIMER
BEAUTIFUL PASS IN AND WRIST SHOD
SCORE!
MCDAVID BURIES BURIES IT FAR.
AS THE DUCKS GOT AD RIGHT THERE.
THE LEG.
TO MCDAVID.
ONE TIMER AND CROSS PASS TO
DRAISAITL FIRST TIME AND OFF.
HE DIGS RIGHT IN.
OFF THE DRAW.
ANOTHER SLAPPER FOR
ANAHEIM.
AND CROSS ICE AND WRIST SHOT
SCORED AND
OF BUY YOUOU FINALLY BREAK OUT.S
TO PASS AND TAKES IT TO THE BAC.
BUT HAD IT STOLEN.
AND CS TARGETS.
RIGHT THERE I'M NOT SURE KASSIAN
OR PULJUJARVI.
ABLE TO MAKE THE STOP.
DUNCAN KEITH.
NET AND POKES IT OFF THE SKATE .
STAYS WITH IT.
ONE HANDED.
SLASHES IT
EMPTY AND HYMAN CHARGES AND
RETRIEVES AND DRAISAITL
BATTLE CONTINUES AND
CLEAR.
CENTRING PASS AND QUICK SHOT
SCORE.E.N IT DOWN TO 17.6
SECONDS.
THIS ONE